Gary should I still pursue a degree in
marketing when you say even though you
say marketers ruin everything I'm a
marketer if not if not then what should
I pursue in regards to
my career because I really want to work
in marketing but approach it differently
than it's been done in the past several
years
gen-i first and foremost I like how you
were reading some sort of card over here
I'd eliminate that from your game but
I'm not razzing um marketers do ruin
everything and I'm a proud and happy
marketer so don't take that literally I
think you should pursue marketing and I
love that you're trying to look the fact
that you even know who I am and are
asking a question on the askgaryvee show
believe it or not makes me think you're
going to be successful and what I would
recommend is the degrees nice and all
but I would highly recommend if you're
still in university to intern at the
places that you most think are
innovating I mean when I think about the
last two classes of vaynermedia interns
and the fact how many of them get hired
into this organization and how great
vaynermedia is as an organization by
comparison to the other people that are
marketing as agencies out there and I
really believe that I think they were
very smart strategic and made the right
move I would give you the same
recommendation get into the walls that
you most believe in and you should mark
it in a different way and 99% of the
places right now won't allow you to do
that so find the other five six seven
ten places that look like this place
which you create the culture to allow